I got into film really by accident a
fortunate sense a fortunate series of
events I wanted to become a diplomat
because I had been born my parents are
both American but I was born abroad and
I grew up amongst a more European
community and when I went back to the
United States when I was fifteen I was a
bit shocked by it and I decided that I
would study to become a diplomat so I
took what we call political science and
the Russian language and I passed all
the exams for the State Department which
is your foreign service and but they
said I was way too liberal politically
to be happy at that job we were
protesting the Vietnam War and
supporting Martin Luther King in the
south and they thought that I would be
unhappy they were probably right so I
went back to do some graduate work but I
then saw an ad in the New York Times and
this never happens for someone from Los
Angeles saying that he wanted to train a
film editor in New York and you will
never see that ad again I answered the
ad and he was butchering the great films
of Fellini Truffaut Visconti from Europe
for late-night television slots because
he wanted them to fit in between 2:00
a.m. and 4:00 a.m. and so here we just
take a whole reel out of a movie like
Rocco and his brothers a great movie by
Visconti and I was horrified by what he
was doing I said you can't do that and
he said well nobody's looking at these
movies at 2:00 in the morning but Martin
Scorsese was and unknown to me and so I
was disgusted by him and I left the job
but I saw an ad for a New York
University film school just a six weeks
course in the summer and I thought I can
just barely afford that so I took it I
wasn't on Scorsese's student film
project I was on another one but someone
had butchered he is a negative of his
student film and because I had learned a
little bit about negative cutting on
this awful job the professor asked is
there anyone here
can help him restore his film and I said
well I'll try and that's how I
accidentally met him so it was an
incredible series of fateful events
luckily for me that occurred and once I
met him and he saw that he could trust
me I think to do what's right for his
movies we began to work together and
fifty years later I'm still working for
her thankfully I had seen some classic
films on a wonderful program in in
America called million dollar movie
where they ran the same movie nine times
in one week and Scorsese was obsessed
with this channel of course and that's
where he saw the films of my late
husband Michael Powell and Emeric
Pressburger he first saw them there and
when he would see their logo which was a
target with an arrow thudding into it he
said oh this is gonna be a really
interesting movie and he would watch it
nine times until his mother said if you
don't turn that off I'm gonna kill you
and I didn't I was actually watching
those movies too at the same time but I
didn't even know who he was so it was in
it was when when I met him he truly
became the reason I became a filmmaker
he trained me he taught me everything
I've ever known about film editing and
his deep passionate love of the history
of film is something he infected me with
and then actually introduced me to my
husband Michael Powell so I've had all
the luck anyone could have in the world
it is a wonderful creative process
between the two of us reaches constantly
are exchanging ideas and doing as I said
what's right for the film you know I
know I bring a great deal to him he
relies heavily on me and it's it's not a
matter of one person having creative
control or something because when you're
in a collaboration that's going back and
forth all the time we make 200 decisions
a day when we're
and it's a joint collaboration that very
important it's the just the best job in
the world
you know his films are always different
he never repeats himself each film is a
new challenge nothing could be more
different than silence and the movie I'm
working on now the Irishman so it's just
the most wonderful job in the world I'm
so lucky to have it I've worked on 24
movies with him
III read the script only once because I
want to see what he he is bringing to
the film as he shoots it because he does
not put into the film the script a great
deal of what he's going to do in the
movie I don't want to be bound either by
a book if the film is based on the book
or the script because I know that when
he gets on the set the film starts to
expand and grow and my job first is to
look at the dailies every day that he
shot the day before and he wants me to
let him know if there's anything I feel
is wrong or which hardly ever happens
and just he wants a in my perspective so
that's why I don't go on the set very
much first of all cuz I don't have time
to go I love to be on the set because I
love watching him work with actors many
of those actors have become friends over
the years so I love to watch that but I
don't have time and also he would rather
I have a cold perspective on what has
been shot I'm not there knowing that the
Sun is going down and the horse just
fell over and the actor is sick and all
that I should not be affected by that I
should see what he got on film and so
then the most important early part of
the film is when he looks at the dailies
with me and he gives me incredible
stream of thoughts about what he has
done I write like the wind fortunately
um and so I tell him what I think he
tells me what he thinks and as he's
telling me what he thinks about each
shot he'll say I'm trying to move this
actor a little bit more to a different
performance here or I think I got it in
the six take
or I hate that shot don't ever show it
to me he's very tough on himself which
is quite remarkable
but this during that process he tells me
his conception for the film you know
what his overall feeling for the film is
and that is incredibly valuable to me so
from those notes and my own notes I
start to do the first assembly of the
film as he's shooting and then when he's
through shooting his favorite part of
filmmaking is editing and so he and I
edit the film together and it's a great
joy I can tell you and as I said it's
just a very lively wonderful interplay
of ideas all working towards the same
goal which is what is right for the
movie I think the most wonderful thing
about editing is that you're given all
this raw material and it's your job to
make choices in this case along with
Scorsese into how to focus the scene you
know when do you cut a cut to a close-up
of of an of one actor rather than the
other when do you use wide shots for
example Scorsese in a famous scene in
Goodfellas where Joe Pesci
says what's so funny about me a very
interesting thing that Marty did there
was he shot that in medium shots there
are no close-ups in that sequence
because he knew that what the reactions
of the people around Joe Pesci
and of Ray Liotta were reacting to the
day the sense of danger that was
building as Pesci just kept saying
what's so funny about what it that you
almost feel that Ray Liotta may get
killed there and the reactions are the
people around him who are laughing at
first and then stop laughing
that's why Square says he shot it in
medium shots not close-ups and that's
something students need to learn
everything doesn't have to be a close-up
you have to know how to use the medium
properly so anyway the all those
decisions we make about how shape a
sequence is it's the most incredibly
creative
act anybody can have I think I think
editors need a strong sense of
discipline a musical sense which
fortunately I had I had been drained to
play instruments in the piano so
Scorsese has a great gift for putting
music to films and I think that is very
important you have to obviously have a
gift for it but you also have to
cooperate with the other filmmakers on
your film particularly the director your
job is to get his vision up on the
screen you have to give him his chance
to do it the way he wants to first then
he's usually able to see if that doesn't
work and you come up with another
solution
sometimes when score says he comes and
I've created four different edits of a
scene for him because there are so many
options and then together we decide
which option to use but your job must be
you have to not I think let your ego
play too much of a role in this because
your job is to do what's right for the
film that's most important
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]